so we're getting an album in the next
couple months
um videos dope uh I saw that uh Joe
Budden was a little critical of this
record he's a fan of you guys obviously
but uh was that just coming with having
Maul in the video I mean I think
definitely Mall played a part in that I
think we knew once Maul was in the video
I mean it's crazy because I
um I I wasn't thinking about it at all
and then I it hit me I was like oh you
know what oh my Joe's gonna probably
have something to say about because he
said you guys talk right you know we DM
in person here and there he's an r b fan
like he talks about r b a lot yeah he he
you know he's he's good for saying a lot
of real things but he's also good for
just kind of just saying things
sometimes so it is what it is you know
he's
he I think he said we dropped an album
in 2016 and then another one in 2019 and
so we don't drop enough for him and I
was like that is not our album the
history I don't know that's not accurate
at all but shout out to Joe you know
whatever it is what it is she just can't
he's just not the division Wikipedia he
thinks he is yeah and sometimes he's
just wrong on records wrong this one's
already proven that he's went out and
you know he said what he said and then
you know I think the same
maybe like a few days later we heard
most number one added song to Urban
radio you know so
you're wrong I think it's like I think I
watched that clip
um and I think I think he's probably
like it's kind of like uh if you're like
a really big fan of like an underground
rapper right and then they put out like
a a song with Drake or some crazy and
you're just like
you didn't have to you know what I mean
I feel like that that was more his
perspective I don't agree because I love
this [ __ ] song I think the song is
great but I think that like I feel like
you know everybody who
most fans who are with you from the
beginning when you have that first real
big splash they're kind of like you know
what I mean so maybe he was just
speaking from that perspective maybe you
know I and one thing about this song
that I I have noticed whether it's you
know a critic or just like a
a casual listener a fan even is
it's it sticks with you in a way that's
different so I think that even if on
first listen you don't want to like it
right on second listen you realize that
you kind of do what you might not want
to say even if you don't like it it's
going to be in your future you can't get
it out of your head so it's just it's
just that kind of song which is cool